une
[Musique]
dans la légendaire grèce l'une de
wedding chapel fois de traditionnelle
marche nuptiale
sitôt son d'elvis que ketty des jo ont
choisi d'unir leurs destinées
un couple formé durant la pandémie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons des styles nous marier avec
grèce car tout était fermé à cause de la
qu'ovide ne voulions pas attendre deux
ans alors nous sommes venus avec est
pourquoi pas être mariée par lviv que
demander de mieux
par les temps qui courent des mariages
comme celui-ci brandon paulhan célèbre
jusqu'à 45 par jour
la ville a traversé des crises mais
d'une telle magnitude jean paul on a des
jeunes est connue qu'elle annie proulx
vente pour une ville basée sur le
tourisme voire vegas dans sept états
s'étaient créés fier et terrible
économiquement mon show à las vegas ce
paradis artificiels au milieu du désert
ont connu la pire crise économique de
son histoire pour se réinventer après
les attentats du 11 septembre et la
récession de 2008
venus avait accéléré son virage familial
élise et sur céline dion
cette fois encore la diva de charlemagne
vient à la rescousse
las vegas l'a accueilli à bras ouverts
elle a redéfini le monde du
divertissement à las vegas elle a lancé
une mode est réellement changer les
choses
la majorité des touristes internationaux
ne sont pas encore de retour mais dans
les rues les bars les hôtels ou les
casinos à l'exception des employés
presque plus personne ne porte le masque
ni le traîna promiscuité wii 2
nous voyons enfin la lumière au bout du
tunnel et ce n'est pas un train le
resort world vient tout juste d'ouvrir
without world est un projet titanesque
de 4 milliards 300 millions de dollars
il vient tout juste d'être inaugurée il
ya compter de novembre
il accueillera en résidence céline dion
l'industrie du divertissement a dépassé
celle des jeux de hasard
c'est pourquoi il était crucial pour un
nouveau venu comme le whizzer world de
se poser en présentant des concert de
super stars
la fête a repris et vegas a hâte de se
remettre de sa gueule de bois
mais le pari est risqué ici 40% de la
population est vaccinée et le
déconfinement est extrêmement rapide
toutefois le poumon économique
artificielle du nevada peut compter sur
une autre carte cachée dans sa manche
le cirque du soleil qui à travers les
néons s'apprête à briller de nouveau
parce qu'avec bus pour croire en sa
chance ici n'est bien lexandre chartier
radio canada las vegas